[Music]
the chair
lit up
[Music]
welcome everyone i mean how's it going
bros mate be it today we're looking at
another tlc couple
another mess two individuals who are
just not right for each other
not right for anyone perhaps you ever
wonder why some people are just single
forever well
this is the reason why we're looking at
aladdin and laura
don't know anything about him and i like
to keep it that way let's go
he's from qatar okay
i'm sure there's gonna be some cultural
uh differences
we've seen this before now who's the
ugly one all right definitely allowed
years old i'm from tunisia but i'm
leaving qatar
all right i'll send foreign i am muslim
and i work
as a personnel
all right i can't wait to see laura
place your bed on how laura looks like
right now for me i'm looking good always
you know like i'm a
brat pete or something you know well
then i'd meet my wife
but then and then
uh why was that funny i don't even know
why i laughed
she make me happy oh okay crazy
some people you know they will argue
because she's more old than you
but she's what i like to eyes and the
blunt
all right i chose laura because i love
her
why did that sound like it was at a gun
point i chose her
because i love her i swear i meet her in
social media
she's a little picture she's just sexy
you know i say no
was that the photo that you looked at i
wouldn't
all right she's just sexy you know he
must really want a blonde girlfriend if
that's what he goes for no offense of
course laura
if you're watching this is he waxing his
beard
like what hey hey hey where you gonna
say aladdin
hey she's more beautiful than the
pictures you know beautiful than
the pictures you know so i tell her they
are baby
she accept you know and we married in
the day nine
whoa why
why would it why would you do that
jesus christ in tunisia it's not allowed
you know to sleep together before the
wedding
oh this explains a lot but after we get
married we will have a lot of jiggy
jiggy
why am i watching this nice face mask
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that god damn it
sometimes she gets jealous not some time
always
okay we found the problem you know i
need to send her a picture before i saw
her i'm with who you know
why i'm tired she have a problem for
trust you know because oh my god some
things from her
old experience you know and she put on
me now okay i love you
can you imagine look i am with muhammad
here he's real here mohammed wait
jesus all right get spicy i like that
video
i blocked her this week what oh my god
this is the problem always between us
you know every new follower i have
we ask
what am i supposed to do
all right at least that's based come on
seems exhausting
i heard recently it's a thing where like
if people get jealous
because they're projecting because they
are likely cheating
is that a thing that's what i heard at
least that makes sense
i block her yeah she called down
and then i unblock her again and they
start talking with her and she she
listened to me
you found the formula that works we
argue over and over
and over and over and again and again
sounds like a good relationship i'm glad
you guys got married seems
was like a great time enjoying me here
in qatar
the problem is coming the problem is
coming she's coming
now she will be with me and i am the man
she need to answer to me
and if she don't it will be a big
problem in our relationship
i have a feeling it will definitely be a
big problem
all right let's check this out i'm
excited
yeah even better than the photos eh
i don't wanna be mean but come on i'm
leaving for guitar in
eight days i'm not all right
not me i'm just saying she looks a lot
older i mean she is 51 so she looks
alright sure
but on the photos she did not look 51.
hi welcome to farawella
how can i help you today kind of would
like to look around and
see what you have men of his culture
aren't exactly adventurous
unfortunately sometimes i have faked it
to get it over with
so i want to get him at a spot
in intimacy where i'm having as much of
a good time
as he's having you never even
uh are you familiar with these they've
been around for some time
okay yeah right right so her solution is
to buy a guitar
probably one of the instructional
manuals we have is sex for dummies
sexy sex for dummies
imagine getting that from your wife
i like to say yeah you need time
communication yeah
well you can just talk to each other see
what you like give a man that
book and marriage over i don't give a
[ __ ]
not that i'm saying he's a dummy but he
sure could use it
on tv too brave enough to tell him that
he wasn't rocking my world in the bed so
i told
everyone on television worldwide i am
not brave enough to tell him
face-to-face but i'll tell it on the
show no problem
okay i definitely oh she actually bought
it uh now i do have a question i saw
some cream over there oh coochie cream
yes amazing oh i can i i'm just
i'm i no i ain't not i i don't want to
watch that
i am 51 years old originally from
toronto canada
originally no one gives a [ __ ] i don't
know why americans always do this i'm
from the midwest
i'm what i don't [ __ ] care god
i'm from sweden in the middle you're
from america
nothing else matters 30 year old person
yeti is it me
wait he's not even oh he's 29 yeah she's
51.
just 22-year difference what the year is
just number
yeah i keep saying that let me see your
six-pack
but we just started to chit chat so i
mean this is on me and marcia talks
he said would you be interested in
coming over here
why are we watching this meeting me i
just want to see them fall apart what
the come on
so before i go to guitar i want to tell
ludwing
exactly what's going on in my life oh
it's so cool
i will be dropping a lot of bombs on him
today
so we've been talking for over a year
and
i actually i uh i i
uh i kind of married him
oh he hasn't talked she hasn't told her
son already married him yeah
and nine days after i met him
it blows my mind that she married
somebody
after nine days of meeting him
i mean what is she thinking about
the six-pack probably why do people keep
doing this
why oh we fell madly in love
so happens all the [ __ ] time
doesn't mean you have to get married god
i don't want to get married because uh
statistics are always so bad and we're
like yeah what people
are pulling it down the statistics a
little bit don't you think god
where are you gonna live i'm leaving for
guitar
what's he doing he works on guitar if i
play
myself in her shoes um i would be taller
because she uses high heels
um
okay all right we got a comedian i
personally would not
leave the comfort that we have in
america
especially knowing laura lee and the
comforts that she likes
i think that she will suffer a little
bit who is he because he has a very
strong accent maybe he's from the
midwest and that's why
we have that marriage license hence why
i got married in nine days
[Music]
you understand a little clearer enough
what a snark yeah yeah you understand
all clear now
there's a cultural difference okay you
dummy schmuck
you don't get it aren't you the same
with [ __ ] i do not understand your logic
even though we are married on paper we
have not had the official
tunisian three-day wedding as of yet
how old is this guy yeah tell him
you saw his pictures that's what i'm
asking tell him
he's turning 30.
no let me tell you something a lot of
young men like older women
yeah but like is different than marriage
marriage is about
looking into the retirement years and
how he's going to
change your diapers
no i love this guy i mean
yes i told him that too he will be yeah
you know like
don't you think that he wants to have a
family
i know he would like to have children do
you think
you are capable i
honestly i don't know maybe like
he can give you a book or something
about it you don't know
how to have babies when you're 60 or
dummies
technically i am
my fear has always been if he can't have
a child with me someday he
could meet a woman that could give him a
baby
and make him walk away from our marriage
so yeah it's in
it's back there in my i mean your
marriage is very precious i mean
you've been married you've been together
for a very long time so it would be
a shame if something happened to it all
right go to qatar
when i see aladdin he is so
happy to see me honey oh my god
it just makes me feel a lot more relaxed
i can't all just hang on
loud gorgeous wow
don't get us arrested i forget the
the rules i eat everything so i hug a
chest i hug and they give her a kiss
let's go you're together now you're like
on the airport you can do it
how are you i'm glad to be here my
goodness
i haven't seen laura for six months now
laura she looked a little bit different
what to do yeah she gained some weight
you know
so it's okay
[Music]
my goodness hey
i am surprised to see that he's brought
all of his friends
i really just wanted to have a little
bit of time
just the two of us to go over
how he's been treating me than to kind
of
force a fake smile but
oh god wait so she wanted to go and just
yell at him right away
are you serious i have to fake a smile
of course he brought his friends then
they're there for protection i'm going
to
talk about this later
talk about what this is what i feel i
feel they want to do gg
very quick she's sitting right there i'm
so confused
she gained some weight but it's okay
fake smile
it's okay i'm a good person not only
does she look old enough to be his mom
she acts like it too we're gonna talk
about yeah what that
nominated for best actor
i feel like they do this because they're
on the show and they're just trying to
like look at a good person i guess all
right
green card now please thank you aled and
i
are on our way to see our new apartment
why why that face rent it for us
why did she talk like that all right we
know he's just a little bit
concerned about cockroaches because they
lived in his old place so
that's a little bit of a concern of mine
oh aren't you aren't you forgetting
something laura you gotta give him the
book
tonight i hope to take him to unknown
territories all right i'm not watching
this i am here for the drama
okay what the hell let's watch this
couple fall apart
ooh explosive pipe yes finally
come on come on please can you tell me
why
honey don't tell me it's for back
massage
oh he found the vibrator right just wait
until he gets to book the gj
yeah the virginia what do you want to
say well do you have to have a plastic
veggie you could just use your hand
oh you and you you need to have this one
well i guess i could just use my hand
too so
it's ridiculous you know it's not though
it's for
us i'm trying to keep my cool
however he's really starting to tick me
off now wait
you're losing your cool oh what i'm not
enough for you just tell me
i've told you things in the past where
i said you need to work on some things
i don't do i tell you so what i don't
like like
well then that's why i have the plastic
thing that'll do it
i see aladdin's age come through when
it comes to communication especially
when it comes says the one that speaks
passive aggressively constantly are you
[ __ ] serious
yeah he must have been a virgin right
what do you expect give the man some
time
they don't even tell me before well if
you were talking to me
what i'm talking to because the week
before i came you weren't talking very
much to me
because you had me blocked i block you
because
when we fight you change like other
person i don't even know you
yeah i believe that she's trying to hold
it in right now you can tell
mama is going to be sleeping with us
it wouldn't
there obviously is not going to be any
jakey jiggy going down tonight
why a lot of money in here
it's cash here you think you're in qatar
you'll pay with the car oh my goodness
honey this is for pay uh our
wedding in indonesia the men pay
everything
in our wedding it's huge speaks
need a lot of money you'll
[Music]
and i have talked about having children
i wish that you could just go to the
bedroom and have jiggy jiggy and
have kids but for me it that's just not
possible
can she stop saying jiggy jiggy please
is that all this is about
[Music]
whoa it's nice no she's cringing oh my
god
honey it's a lovely dress
for somebody skinny you can look in the
mirror i already saw myself in the
mirror
i'm the fat angel you put up on your
christmas tree you know the one that's
all pretty with all the sparkles
when i'm in the change room and i hear
him carrying on
i don't know if it's just me or what but
it seems like this
there's flirtatious conversations
it's kind of insecure especially when i
don't know a word that they're saying
what were you saying to her huh what
were you just chatting about
yeah you talk about like why you chose
me i tell her she chose me because i'm a
handsome
time you know he's not too bad looking
[Music]
she's look nice you're trying on a
wedding dress not a sky driving
yeah and you have to try them out that's
like all right let's see the wedding
honey i love you so much
[Music]
sweet finger oh it's nice
now they've been together forever
[Music]
i can't tell that was a baseball are you
my husband yes
when i put the ring in her finger i want
to kiss her you know but
you know the culture so i can not even
on your wedding what
i got into a big fight with aladdin
oh no i can't believe it girl creeping
up in his social media
and i had asked him previously
to remove this woman this morning i
actually realized
he had unblocked me and i text him
right away because i'm like i i don't
even have a desire
to come and see you anymore and
i don't know if i'm going to a person
who even loves me
surprisingly against all odds and all
logic and common sense i do
actually think he does you don't know i
love you or not
maybe
[Music]
so surprise surprise they got divorced
can you believe it
unbelievable what i did doesn't it
doesn't deserve a divorce
wait what did she do what did you do
okay i still care about you
i still care i definitely still care
about you you know
i would like you to kind of soften up
just a little bit and not be so hard and
hateful
sorry why am i laughing
that's hilarious well done okay so
apparently she repeatedly publicly
humiliated him
after he treated her like a queen i
don't know about that
yeah green card meme or not it did seem
like
she got more out of that i don't know
i'm just judging from the videos
i have no clue but that's kind of the
point
god i love these videos that's such a
mess i never want to hear the word
cheeky jiggy ever
ever again thank you for watching
another tlc video if you enjoyed
smash like subscribe i don't even say
smash like so [ __ ] cringe
uh you know what's not cringe bro there
it is see you tomorrow
[Music]
later
ah